rêver de l'été à quelques semaines des
vacances de juillet une grave question
se pose pour les femmes et pour les
hommes également ce au moins qu'ils ont
droit aux chambres voix au chapitre êtes
vous une pièce ou deux pièces autrement
dit êtes-vous bikini ou maillots de bain
pu traditionnel nathalie journée raymond
chapelât ils répondent ni redescendre de
la saison objectif flairé la tendance
chaque été c'est le même casse-tête
doit-on se dénuder un peu beaucoup ou
pas du tout
réponse des pros du maillot
ce sont d'abord les bikinis pareille
sortie bikini avec fuchsia vert pomme le
orange couleur soleil évidemment
alors pour les hommes nous avons
également les boxers très sexy qui sont
très très beau qui vont très près aux
offres
le bonhomme en boxer donc la sirène en
bikini on peut aussi chercher
l'inspiration ailleurs et bien d'un
floride miami c'est les couleurs
chamarrées des belles couvert ça allait
acheter quelques-uns quand même
en france aussi a eu des défilés des
marqueurs de belles couleurs avaient
défilé à la mode la suite à juan les
pins
le temple de la mode estivale une âme de
roanne dans les maillots de bain sont en
vente aux états unis
c'est très soirée un peu non le maillot
de soirée pas encore un must
le string a pris du plomb dans l'aisne
je n'ai pas confiance et conscience
la ficelle garde tout de même ses
inconditionnels encore mieux c'est sûr
ne rien mettre c'est encore la meilleure
solution pour éviter de commettre la
faute de goût qui vous pourrit votre été
dernières consignes elle vient d'un sage
des plages le fait plusieurs la vente
dans l'alger peu plus peut-être dû vous
secourir par 45 degrés c'est pas
toujours évident jeunes et moins jeunes
cet été sur la plage c'est surtout comme
vous le sentez